you got about five minutes before six
hey you've not made your plans for the
weekend check out Nate on the town maybe
you want to visit the largest the
biggest student-run farmers market in
the country this is going to be in
downtown Summerlin on Friday sponsored
by Green our planet 9 30 in the morning
and they're going to shut it down at one
in the afternoon everything there is
grown by local students on their
campuses and all the proceeds go right
back to those schools to help continue
the garden programs Saturday maybe you
want to visit the hollow hollow Market
this is on Ferguson's on East Fremont 11
in the morning until one shop eat live
music and the LV plant Collective is
going to be there for Earth Day you can
do a little swap maybe you got a plant
that you're just having trouble with you
can't figure it out you can swap it out
for a different one also there's the
Great Northwest Country Fest this is up
at Lone Mountain Park in the far
Northwest Valley it's free noon until
the sun goes down with a bunch of live
music a little bit of a rodeo exhibition
and another different farmers market and
of course some food trucks so lots of
options sure are yeah my conundrum plant
I'm having trouble with
it's working it's a conundrum they're
all conundrums